das ist mir lieblingsfluss
letztes Jahr bin ich vom Quellgebiet im
Berner Oberland ihrem Lauf entlang Crist
so wichtig ist
und mit denenzen
bis sie im Kanton Aargau gelandet bin
sogar mehr Wasser aus der Reihe vom
Graubünden bis nach Koblenz bringt
jetzt wird die Teegarten vom Rio
kennenlernen und das
[Musik]
232 km vor der Schweiz bis Niederlande
in Nordsee
die französische Grenze markiert und ich
in der Schweiz
[Musik]
376 Kilometer und werden dabei auf
verschiedene
im Kanton Aargau zieht weiter besitzt
deutsche Bad Säckingen
[Musik]
der drei und Angelpunkt von der
Schweizer Rohstoffversorgung liegt hier
am 3 ländereck wo Deutschland Frankreich
und Schweiz aufeinander treffen und Chef
et Nordsee auslaufen
hier im rihhafen
Schweiz noch nie gesehen
es ist nicht so so perfekt und ich finde
halt die unperfekte Ort eigentlich am
schönsten und ich glaube es ist noch
nicht so viel Leute kenne oder es ist
irgendwie für mich ist aber bitte kein
eckli so wie wichtig ist
Stadt aus richtigs Basel Meidling mega
wichtig also es ist einfach gerade im
Sommer ich finde wenn man kein Wasser
hat in der nähe ich also
der Riesen
Energiequellen irgendwie und einfach so
sich so gechillt einfach bei uns aber im
Sommer können auch alle User
wie langweilig
darum glaube ich machen
neue Locations
also wirklich
besonders attraktive Stefan hier ist es
Kulturzentrum und das Restaurant in Form
von einer originalen
die stellenrichtung speziell den oder
berühmten nein
[Musik]
Youtube
normalerweise bringt sie ihre
zum anderen
[Musik]
aus Nacht
mit ihrer Industrie
inspiriert vor ihrem
[Musik]
weitere Kanton Aargau von
kaiseraugstar
Grenzübergang zwischen der Schweiz und
Deutschland
[Musik]
willkommen in Möhlin
willkommen auf dem
ringhaus Musiker mit Merlin verbunden
[Musik]
er will mir das selber
eine
frachtstromförmig geflossen also
das ist Vorfahrt nach irgendwie einfach
gefloht war schon immer sehr schade
springen Heiko mega erfolgreiche
jetzt momentan bin ich richtig Krise
kreative Krise meistens
was will ich noch sagen was will ich
noch erzählen was will ich noch
schreiben
mega es läuft alles super aber
was ich noch auf dem Plan ich muss ein
bisschen nur realisieren
ja
mit du und zieht hat und Grundlagen
[Musik]
5 Minuten 2
produce
und einfach so das Äußere kreative
PlayStore wo nicht nur Musik stattfindet
sondern auch wir sind da [ __ ] Fälle am
Kochen
Schmutz ist ein sehr guten Freund schon
über zwei Jahren und ein absoluter
spitzekoch was ganz schön
[Musik]
spannend
findest die Offenheit gefallen
[Musik]
Kanton Zürich
im Kanton Schaffhausen zwischen rivau
und Thiessen
[Musik]
Kraftwerk Eglisau Glattfelden
morgen früh noch mit nabuibettet
obwohl der Tag hat so sommerlich warm
werden
es ist scheiße vor insgesamt 22
Kraftwerken
[Musik]
fasziniert vom zimmerhang zwischen
wettrund und Fluss
das hat extrem viel miteinander
Daniela Biedermann ich freue mich beim
Schweizer Fernsehen Moderatorin von der
gesundheitshandy Polski mittlerweile
das Kraftwerk ist in erster Weltkrieg
gebaut worden und zwar von 1915 bis 1920
und der Schonung
2012 moderne Maschine Kraftwerke
runterland profitiert
[Musik]
unter anderem fürs Radio 2
S
trotz der unglaublichen
überhaupt kein Problem
[Musik]
und warum ist das Warten so und so ich
finde das super spannend
mit Dörfer zum Schluss vor der Fahrt
kurz vor Rüdlingen auf schiffsbrück der
Kapitän nicht
der Peter spaziert vor Rüdlingen zurück
auf eg
mit ziemlich
[Musik]
Schweiz
mit zwei Wasserfällen Island und
Norwegen gehört
über 50 Jahre zu ihrem Leben
[Musik]
der IV gehört links zum Kanton
Schaffhausen rechts zum Kanton Zürich
[Musik]
ursprünglich ist es Transport
und mir als Familie sind natürlich der
Zahni unterwegs
traditionell motorlos wegling aus
Massivholz
nur mit stachelem Ufer entlang Fluss
muss
[Musik]
mit dem Ruhedruck gibt meine Nummer a
sondern stührend gleichzeitig
[Musik]
2014 Familie Pfalzgraf ihres jungs-
der Umstand ist
keine Familie wo stehst du momentan im
Leben
so lange her dass ich immer wieder muss
nachrechne und ich glaube das ist
eigentlich gutes Zeichen
oder acht Jahre also sind jetzt acht
Jahre aber es wird jedes Jahr anders zum
Glück ich finde es immer nur recht die
Radwanderung
[Musik]
ich finde eigentlich unbedingt also
sie ist eigentlich schön wenn man merkt
er wird nicht vergessen will
du lebst die eigentlich ist mir das
passiert und dann habe ich an silvante
[Musik]
mit erste wedlingserlaubnis überhaupt
nimmt ihn
auf der Highlights bis Vierthaler
hier kann ich aber wieder
stromaufwärts gegen Flussverlauf vom Reh
wieder richtig Osten ist die letzte
Stadt vor montessee stehen ri aber
av-tümer der neue Tag früher Morgen zehn
Kilometer östlich und zwar im deutschen
vor der geht dem Boden
statt Rorschach
jetzt haben wir hoffen auf die nächste
Person wo mir ihre Welt im Wasser noch
bringt
es ist mit der Villach
und vom Frühling bis sie herbststimme
die ehemalige SRF Moderatorin gönnt
stundenlang der im Wasser bleiben und
die Regierung
und ich glaube mich
entfernt wohnt Marion Preuß seit 21
Jahren
aus was sie braucht ich kann sehr gut
vor der Schweiz
also nein mir das nicht langweilig ich
mache alles Vortrag ich mache
geschlechtsfahrten auf dem Untersee nein
mir wird es wirklich nicht langweilig
ich hoffe ich kann das nur lang machen
mit Fahrrad aufstehen
und nimmt es mit stehen im Mario Preuss
historische Stadtführungen der Art was
Wasser vom See wieder ins Bett vom Fluss
drängt wird Marion Preuß hat sich nie
gerne in der Formel drücken angefangen
Chance Mädchen
und es ist ja alles vorgeschrieben
gesehen also vom morgendlichen Dauerlauf
bis übers eiskalt Dusche aber das haben
die wenigstens noch halte aber so
wünschte ich mir immer alles vorkaut
gesehen und das habe ich überhaupt nicht
selber entscheiden und das ist
vielleicht auch der Grund warum ich nie
im Leben
sei stark gestellt
ich kann auch gehen wenn ich will was
ich schlussendlich beim Schweizer
Fernsehen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
aus Stadt zerschmau urkundlich erwähnt
im Jahr 1267
[Musik]
Reformation oder also ich meine das
einfach mehr so mitmachen trotzdem alle
Ortschaften der unisono zum reformierte
Glauben übertragen wenn du den
Gegendruck
oberhalb verstehen
[Musik]
und entspricht auch nach der letzten
Sanierung vor 15 Jahren mit dualterliche
Erscheinungsbild von 1200 bis 1422
vorher
und eigentlich fühle ich mich 100%
bestätigt bin ich ja immer das gemacht
was ich habe und der Schluss eigentlich
bin ich jetzt da gelandet und insofern
ist das eigentlich ja 100% richtig
um die nach Diät doppelt zu erreichen
muss man über den unteren er vereinig
für Gottlieben mit dem Schloss aus dem
dritten
Konstanz im Bodensee
[Musik]
St Gallen Boden
Tochter vom nino ist hier aufgewachsen
[Musik]
wir schottische Schriftsteller Max
Frisch gesehen hat wir riefen
Arbeitskräfte und es kamen Menschen dass
die italienische MigrantInnen und
MigrantInnen
wir alle andere als Kind sowieso 2013
was hätte eigentlich mit
dem Leben
eigentlich ziemlich schnell ganze grosse
wichtige
Entschuldigung fantastisch
[Gelächter]
ja
einfach
Heimat
ja
Heimat gefühlt
Bern ist für mehr
Rom obwohl schon seit 1970 im Kanton
Bern wohnt sie ist Schweizer Geschichte
aber nimmt hier auf dem Rorschacherberg
[Musik]
da ist jetzt das Haus wo sie nachdem das
Forum weggegangen sind 1947
vor der Familie wo jetzt hier wohnt
haben
[Musik]
am Heimat
Heimat geht diese Identität und ich
glaube dass ich dir mit den
verschiedenen Orten
immer wieder entwickelt
[Musik]
Liechtenstein
die einzige Schweizer Ortschaft auf der
östlichen Seite vom Opera
und der ganz eigene Mundart so gut aus
hallo
ja alle Wörter haben
er das lustige Wortspiel war 76-Jährige
und viel auseinandersetzen
[Musik]
und die jeder Geschichte ist
Persönlichkeit sehr von der Mensch denen
wo mir die Geschichte verzählt hat
mehr Hunde auch schöne musikalische
Sprache und das so sprach gibt es auf
der ganzen Welt nicht
viel größere
wie zum Beispiel hier im Diepoldsauer
Strandbad
und immun Aspekt durch Blüten fröhlichen
Menschen schlagen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ist der Grenzübergang
Polizeikommandant hätte der Jahr 1938
gehen Sie zurück bitte lassen Sie uns
rüber
wir müssen sie einlassen alle ist der
Untersuchungsrichter mit der Arbeit
beginnt müssen sie mit ihrer
Suspendierung rechnen
auf persönlichen
Projekten
besonders wichtig
darüber bin
ich denke Gesetz übertrieben
es Sprichwort Zeit die grossen die
kleine Wasser es braucht manchmal
[Musik]
am südlichsten Punkt vom Ländle
das Wasser kommt vom Ursprung das ist
geschmolzener Schnee aus der Berger
[Musik]
unglaublich spannend wenn man irgendwo
herakort was man nicht kennt wo man sich
nicht wohlfühlt wo man aber überfordert
ist wo adrenalinkon oder Emotionen kann
was unterbewusst sie einmal sieht nein
Stopp halt bis daher Schritt weiter und
das vor allem kleinteilschiri war an der
Start von rein Abfahrt in Kitzbühel und
die innere schreit und will nicht und
jeden Moment musst du einfach der Kopf
Rippen im Buch und sieht nicht jetzt und
du lernst wirklich Ruhe obwohl sie
innerlich brodelt aber du lernst mit dem
Umzug und ich glaube das ist ja Qualität
wo nicht
stelle ich wieder Marco Büchel
beschreibt braucht
Extremsport oder 50 Jahre Gedichte
stehender lang
es gibt drei Regler beim basejumperlen
und ich hatte erste Punkt aus
der zweite Punkt
er ist ein besserer Jumper seit ihr als
ein besserer fachlichen besserer
Springer gesehen und wenn immer etwas
passieren kann dann kannst du mir alle
mal passieren und ich hatte Schirm
gesprungen und das ist jetzt 13 Jahre zu
13 Jahren
aber das juckt mich auch noch gell
Profis
bis zum Restaurant Marcel Schaufel
wie schwierig ist der Schritt vor der
Karriere zu der neuen Karriere gesehen
ja das ist nicht so einfach gesehen
also Beispiel Freunde bin ich definiert
sie durch Zahlen dauerhaft durch Zahlen
Trainingsläufe nicht macht wie viel
Umläufe nicht gemacht Wiederholungen
definiert hat ob ihr erfolgreich Bio
oder nicht nach dem Rücktritt sind die
Zahlen der klassisch warte ich noch mal
und das ist am Punkt
ich habe mir das weggenommen
und dann bin ich schon er hat zwei Jahre
lang hatte ca vor allem Weltcup Brenner
begleiten als Zuschauer das hätten sie
ist
[Musik]
das ist mein absoluter Lieblingsplatz
bis im Land das endlich Gipfelkreuz
verliert der Standorte Rundumblick
ansonsten
[Musik]
die ganze Aussicht
zwischen lichtenstein
bis da ist Rio fast
jetzt
mit Entfernung
[Musik]
ich bettet zwischen der schönen Berge
ist der Egon vom Kanton Graubünden die
erster Linie der Verkehrsknotenpunkt auf
dem Weg Bündner Ferienregionen
[Musik]
Landquart ist aber mehr als das
vor allem verlegt wo ich aufgewachsen
sind
so wie für eine Schauspielerin
und Mini Verbindung
ich vermisse es wahnsinnig ich bin prägt
[Musik]
mit 26 Kilometer weiter
vom Kalender
[Musik]
da wo der hinterry links und der vordere
am vordere entlang liegen bekannte
Naturspektakel wieder Grand Canyon von
der Schweiz drehschlucht und nicht
traditionell insgesamt
[Musik]
hier ist ein Moment wo man sich muss
entscheiden
warum
ich gesehen habe dem Thomas
das ist die weniger rationale
Entscheidung ich warte auf Intuition
setzen mit dem
konfliktskämpfen kann wenn im zweiten
darüber denken
sowieso im Leben aber das wissen ist
okay
du kannst nicht zurückkommen
und sich den döttinnen zu befreien ist
dann ist dann wieder richtig
[Musik]
spätestens nach Thusis in einer bis zu
300 Meter höheren
[Musik]
Via Mala
wir sind den Reihen hinaufgezogen durch
manches Schatt gefällt
[Musik]
entlang der blauen frischen Wogen zu
seinem hohen Quell empor
der Fels er ist so zeichnet da passiert
Skulptur und der wird ständig geschafft
sich immer wieder ist schönes berührt
ein
es ist wirklich Witze magische Ort
der hintere über das so gemächlich
erfinden das ist schwer der Geburtskanal
wo ich das Gefühl haben neue
Informationen über Nachrichten wieder
relativ gemächlich aber da muss es wie
üblich werden
[Musik]
um den Mitte von dem Naturspektakel
und nach dem Süden hin das Jahr unter
anderem Adaption vom John knittels im
Romanus im Jahr 1934 Maler
Region Via Mala erstreckt sich übers
schamsertal ob es zu der
Wasser vom hinterry stürzt
[Musik]
und superschönen Fluss oder durch
speziell dran sie die Granitblöcke
[Musik]
Kletterer
Sambach
zusammen mit jeder Familie Betriebe
infiziert sie sind im Ball madrisco
der 37-Jährige
[Musik]
es ist kurz vor der sechsten morgen
mir mega
jedes Wasser geben mit jedem Schritt
immer wie nachher immer wieder zum
Ursprung vom hinterlegt
[Musik]
also für mich ist es riesige
Herausforderungen
aber
das ist mir mehr persönlich es ist mega
wichtig sie hier ja ich meine darüber
der Ferien und der Schnee und das ist
das ist eigentlich
reinste und ursprünglichste Wasser vom
Rio der hintere fließt und ja das sind
die Schneekristall wo zu Tröpfen werden
oder
in der Nordsee landen
[Musik]
Konsequenzen
und mit mimproblem auf Mini Art und
Visum
es tut mir leid
das Backen
oder ins Mittelmeer
also gut
was in basok
Möglichkeiten
kurz vor dem 3400 und 2 Meter höher
[Musik]